THE LAW DURING THEIR
INVESTIGATION INTO THE
HILLARY CLINTON EMAIL SCANDAL.
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE CORRESPONDENT
CATHERINE HERRIDGE JOINS US
TONIGHT TO TELL US WHAT SHE IS
HEARING.
>> Reporter: THEY DESCRIBED IT
IN DETAIL IN THE BALLPARK OF
SEVERAL HUNDRED PAGES.
THE TIMELINE IS FIRMING UP WITH
TENTATIVE DATES ON THE CALENDAR
FOR PUBLIC TESTIMONY FROM
MICHAEL HOROWITZ.
WHILE THE OFFICE IS NOT
COMMENTING ON THE FINDINGS, THE
SOURCE SAYS THERE IS EVIDENCE OF
CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR.
FOX NEWS CONFIRMED REPORTS OF AT
LEAST ONE REFERRAL.
WHEN DEPUTY DIRECTOR ANDREW
McCABE WAS FIRED, HE TOLD THE
DEPUTY GENERAL THAT HE DISAGREED
WITH THE FINDINGS ARGUING THAT
HIS BOSS KNEW ABOUT HIS
ENGAGEMENT WITH
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" ."
McCABE CLAIMED HE WANTED TO BE
SEPARATED, AND TO CALL ME WAS
PRESSED ON THE ALLEGATION IN HIS
INTERVIEW.
>> DID THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
INTERVIEW YOU ABOUT YOUR
HANDLING OF THE MEMOS?
>> SURE.
HE HAS ALREADY.
AND I EXPECT A REPORT ON THEM.
NOT ON THAT, BECAUSE IT'S
FRIVOLOUS BUT DID I COMPLY WITH
POLICY?
>> THAT BEGAN MONTHS AGO WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
>> Bret: WHAT'S THE LATEST
FROM THE EFFORTS TO OBTAIN THESE
DOCUMENTS FROM THE DOJ AND FBI?
>> THE COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN AND
THEIR TEAMS ARE DONE MEETING
WITH THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
ABOUT RECORDS, AND WITH A
SUBPOENA IN EFFECT, THE ONUS
THEY BELIEVE A LOT IS ON THE DOJ
AND FBI TO MAKE THE DOCUMENTS
AVAILABLE.
THEY HAD OFFERED THE COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN AND THE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN A MEETING
TODAY WITH DEPUTY ATTORNEY ROB
ROSENSTEIN.
FBI DIRECTOR CHRISTOPHER WRAY,
SENIOR INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS,
BUT LAWMAKERS DID NOT RESPOND.
>> I THINK THAT INVITATION WAS
JUST TO COME AND TALK AGAIN.
WE HAVE ASKED FOR DOCUMENTS,
46,000 DOCUMENTS THAT JUSTICE
HAS TOLD US TO GET AN WE'VE
RECEIVED 9,000 OVER THE LAST SIX
MONTHS.